going to take you live now to Camp David
where President Joe Biden is speaking
let's listen in
you stepped up to do the hard work that
I would argue historic work to forge a
foundation from which we can face the
future together the three of us together
and I'm deeply grateful for your
leadership and I look forward to working
with both of you as we begin this new
era cooperation and renew our resolve to
serve as a force of good across
indo-pacific and quite frankly around
the world as well president Yoon let me
turn this over to you
I would like to extend my gratitude to
President Biden for his warm hospitality
last July we met in Vilnius for the NATO
Summit and I'm pleased to be reunited in
about a month
at this symbolic venue of to Camp David
in the history of modern his diplomacy
our trilateral partnership is opening a
new chapter which carries great
significance in my view President
Roosevelt once stated freedom is not a
given but something you fight to win
to make sure that each of our freedoms
is neither threatened or damaged our
three nations must tighten our
solidarity
such is also our promise and mandate
towards our future Generations a
stronger coordination between Korea the
U.S and Japan requires more robust
institutional foundations moreover
challenges that threaten Regional
security must be addressed by us to
building up stronger commitment to
working together
today will be remembered as a historic
day where we established a firm
institutional basis and commitments to
the trilateral partnership
today I hope we will explore together
ways to elevate cooperation between
Korea the U.S and Japan to a new plane
through in-depth discussions
first of all
I would like to express
my sympathy once again for the
devastating damages caused by the
wildfires in Maui Hawaii in order to
provide relief to the affected people
Japan has decided to offer a total of
around 2 million dollars of support I
offer my heartfelt prayer for the
earliest possible recovery of the
affected areas Maya also once again
convey my heartfelt condolences for the
passing away of president
years father and now I would like to
thank
the job for your kind invitation to the
tour of us to Camp David a place with
history
president Yoon I have been
meeting you almost on a monthly basis
since March of this year but
the fact that we the three leaders have
got together in this way I believe means
that we are indeed making a new history
as of today
the International Community is at a
turning point in history
in order to allow the potential of a
lateral strategic collaboration to
Bloom and Blossom
I wish to take this moment to raise
further security the coordination
between Japan rlk and the U.S
to new
heights were strengthening the
coordination between the Japan U.S and
the U.S Iraqi alliances as we deepen our
cooperation in the response to North
Korea I wish to expand and deepen our
collaboration and extensive areas
including Economic Security such as
critical and emerging technology
cooperation and Supply chains
resilience
today I look forward to engaging in a
Frank discussions amongst ourselves in
order to declare a new area of Japan U.S
RFK partnership
I once again express my gratitude
if all Joe's initiative thank you thank
you
politely asked the press to to leave
thank you for coming in
tonight
and we will leave the leaders of the
United States Japan and South Korea as
they get the summit underway in Camp
David in Maryland a historic three-day
Summit as we heard from all the leaders
Joe Biden calling it a new era of
cooperation the South Korean president
calling it a historic day and the
Japanese prime minister saying it was a
turning point in history for the
International Community
let's discuss this further we're joined
by Robert Kelly who's usually based in
South Korea but today joins us from Ohio
he's an expert in Asia Pacific relations
North Korea and China Robert this may
indeed be an extraordinary Summit but
should we expect anything concrete to
come out of it
I think that's really the next big step
um relations between South Korea and
Japan have traditionally not been
particularly good right so to a certain
extent I think this is about showing the
two of them on the same page and sort of
openly and uh you know happily or with
some enthusiasm collaborating with the
United States The Next Step then really
is to actually start to get the concrete
discussions about what the three allies
would do in some particular scenario you
know if there's a conflict with North
Korea and the North Koreans news use a
nuclear weapon like what would we do if
China attacks Taiwan or blockades it you
know what will we do if China blockades
the South China Sea to prevent oil
imports or you know gets into some kind
of armed conflict with the Philippines
which is something that sort of we all
saw just like a week ago you know on
YouTube I mean if this you know what
what are they actually going to do are
they going to be concrete plans whether
it be some kind of you know contingency
planning cell or something like that and
you know that's ultimately where this
needs to lead right it needs to get away
from sort of the big cemetery and
actually get into uh bureaucratic
collaboration operation and that's going
to be difficult I think absolutely and
how then they also ensure that any
agreement is lasting given the political
volatility in the U.S and South Korea
and elections coming up in Japan
yeah that's right that's actually a
really great point and that's actually
one of the reasons why I'm personally a
little bit skeptical on this I live in
South Korea and there I'm you know South
Korean politics is deeply the South
Korean electorate is deeply divided
about rapper or small about sort of
deeper integration and collaboration
with Japan this is something the current
president of South Korea you and satyo
wants very much and he has pushed that
using the powers of the South Korean
presidency the South Korean president
has a lot of room to act sort of
independently on foreign policy and so
he's pushed this pretty hard but I'm not
really convinced that the South Korean
legislature the National Assembly
supports this kind of Engagement and I'm
not sure that the South Korean public
does either right and of course as you
said you know in the United States too
right if Donald Trump gets back into the
presidency in a year and a half you know
all bets are off Donald Trump was a very
irregular Ally uh to to U.S Partners to
East Asia and so I think there's a lot
of domestic
changes that could undercut this in the
future and so it's going to be a
challenge to root this right to sort of
like make it immovable you know and and
something that domestic changes couldn't
shake the White House has been at Great
pains to say this is not about forging
an alliance against China is it though
uh I mean they have to say that right I
mean you know and that's just important
I suppose that they say that right I
mean it's we want to sort of signal to
the Chinese that we don't want a cold
war to we don't want to contain China in
the way that we contain the Soviet Union
in the 40s and 50s we want to avoid
sliding in that direction but I think we
are and I think certainly in the analyst
community and people who sort of outside
of the government people like me you
know professors and analysts I think a
lot of us think that this is probably
aimed mostly at China ostensibly you
know it's probably aimed at North Korea
right I mean North Korea is an acute
threat because we don't really
understand North Korea very well we
don't know why when or why it might use
a nuclear weapon you know they're not
very good on telling us those kinds of
things but the longer term structural
challenge in East Asia I think is what
you're pointing at and is correct right
I mean China's rising and we're all
struggling to figure out how to respond
to that and so sure that I think that's
the background to this debate to this
meeting okay very interesting to talk to
you Robert Kelly thanks for taking the
time to join us there from Ohio